[Music]
um yeah you're anti the the fat phobic
movement
well are we is there short man phobic
I'm just tired like
yeah we're bullied as children and shows
like my brothers would never get away
with me thinking I was a tent oh my God
Austin Adam they would tell me so quick
right no tell me so quick what's holding
you back from being a ten do you think
um what do you need to be a ton you got
a BBL coming no no it'd be a good Arc
you're good for the content no I mean
what's holding me back from being
attacked I just feel like I don't have
like a symmetrical enough face to be a
10. really yeah I mean if I did I'd have
a modeling contract that's okay I guess
I would say about myself yeah definitely
I've never felt like there was any
number of people who were like into me
for my looks so much maybe as I get
older that's the weird thing is as you
start to become like rich and well-known
people start acting like you're
attractive and I'm like there's no way
that you're going to just pull the
[ __ ] wool over my eyes and convince
me that I was good looking all these
years nobody ever treated me that way
really
you're like you're six what four
nice eyes I don't know yeah a nice size
I got a lot of that a lot of fat chicks
telling me I had nice eyes my whole life
I don't know I don't know if I trusted
them but those were actually the chicks
who are into me so I could see it yeah
um I don't know I just think if I was a
10 I would have modeling contracts I
have never been offered a modeling
contract so I don't I don't think I'm
ugly by any means I just don't think I'm
a 10. when I was young in New York City
I had like a friend tall light-skinned
black dude it's like six six or some
[ __ ] and he would stay get an offered
modeling contracts around me like all
the time and nobody ever offered it to
me so you're like what about me yeah I
could do it because I had never thought
about being a model my whole life and
then all of a sudden he's getting
offered this multiple times in front of
me and I did start to kind of feel like
[ __ ] yeah
I don't try to think of my oh I I have
one friend who I think she used to model
but then she got too fat so you wanna
know this this puts it on the
perspective one time there was these two
girls I met when I was living in New
York you know early 20s and one of them
super pretty and one of them was super
ugly like no question about it like the
other one had like the biggest [ __ ]
nose you've ever seen like this massive
hanger she was just I I used to look at
her and just think like how have you not
got a nose job like it's so clearly the
thing that would improve your life the
most whatever but one time I'm on the
train with both of them and I had met
them because of the ugly one right the
ugly one hit me up on MySpace and then
somehow I end up meeting her and her
friend and her friend's super [ __ ]
hot and I just blatantly ended up
hitting on the hot one in front of her
and whatever and then we're all on the
train together and this like 60 year old
lady just goes to the ugly one she just
goes
your friend is so beautiful
and the [ __ ] girl just bursts into
tears and just starts sobbing her
[ __ ] eyes out on the train right in
front of me and in that moment has never
been more clear to me like just how much
privilege a hot chick has and like just
how
Charmed your life is going to be as a
result of having been born with like a
symmetrical face and a nice sized nose
or whatever the [ __ ] it was
friend like that like she's just like
ever and I'm like when she walks out I'm
like I have never seen someone get this
much male attention in my life oh my God
I didn't realize she has really big
boobs too I'm like wow that goes a long
way yeah yeah yeah because most of my
friends like have like a volleyball body
like so it's just like usually like kind
of flat chested big butt like that's
just how we're built usually but
um I don't know if she yeah when we go
somewhere like she has guys go up to her
like all the time and I'm like oh my god
I've never been around someone that gets
this much attention but does that make
you feel bad about yourself or you just
sort of own it no not really I mean I
think when I was younger it probably
would have but now it's like
you know what's funny I saw 1950s dating
advice and it was like stay around a hot
friend because you could get their
leftovers
but that says a lot like at that time
period like women were expected to feel
lucky to have one guy wanted to take
care of them yeah so it's like if a hot
guy goes up to her like maybe he'll have
a friend I don't know like so I don't
really yeah and and most of the guys
that like go up to her
um
I don't know like
actually never mind but when I was
younger I felt like I was way more down
for like quantity than quality which
traditionally you know quality over
quantity that's advice a lot of people
would give you and when I look back in
my life I'm like why were you always so
down to take the fat home girl yeah
because you're a guy that's like your
biological predisposition to stop as
many kids as possible where Like Girls
It's quality over quite and I figured
like nobody's gonna know I'll be able to
keep this low-key
you know
did you ever did you ever so you must
have like have literally not known like
names of the girls you were like
sleeping with I have a list up to like
300. oh wow what a gentleman a Google
doc yes a gentleman and a scholar no I
kept a list my whole life so I can go
back to it but yeah for sure there's
gonna be a ton of names on the list that
I'm just like but and a lot of them too
are like vague descriptions
it'll be like Boston blonde girl in the
woods wow because it's just some chick
I'm at the bar and we went in the woods
yeah it's pretty gross but there's a few
on there like that that would be really
confusing but then I I stopped keeping
track once we started doing it on camera
but I could theoretically go through the
list and compile a full list now
I could I could like go through social
media or whatever and like figure out
all of them
but it would be a lot good memory that's
not there's no memory I would have to
just go through social media and look
through it
yeah but you connected with all of them
on social media no but I posted it
probably at some point or if I looked
through my girls oh my girl could put
the list together okay you know
okay you put it on patreon
just the list yeah nobody wants to see
that that is so terrible
um all right so what else do you have uh
in the works or what are you planning in
terms of your content and everything Oh
and before I ask that I want to ask are
you just like totally [ __ ]
business-wise because I saw you were
like age restricted by the time the
entertain episode already went live and
no I think I broke even on that video
because you made some money before they
did that yeah okay so I think I broke
even maybe I made a little bit but it's
basically with because there is a
sponsorship
yeah so
um but do they get you a lot no really
that was like one of the I mean
sometimes but for the most part no they
would get me more when I did rap
reactions oh that was hell that was like
every video demonetized really yeah just
because it was like violent [ __ ] or what
um it was like the Music Company oh well
that's like copyright yeah yeah so I
like I got like 20 000 subscribers in a
day or ten thousand and
um I like I just stopped doing it
because I like would make no money on
the videos yeah but that's a wild side
of YouTube where the like reaction
Channels with millions of views of like
people reacting to music and they're not
making money on any of the videos but
then they find other ways to make money
I I never did I just was like F this I'm
gonna go a different route I feel you
but all right so new new ideas for the
content or where is it going from here
oh um I just started wife School
so it's like basically me learning
things to like be more traditional
pretty much so
um the first episode as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible